le fmi y vole au secours de la côte
d'ivoire le fonds monétaire
international a approuvé hier une aide
d'urgence de 886 millions de dollars à
abidjan depuis le début de l'épidémie la
maladie a fait six morts et 688
contaminée pour endiguer la propagation
du virus un couvre-feu a été décrété
entre 21h et 5h du matin dans tout le
pays en revanche pas de confinement
généralisée même si les habitants et ils
ont été invités ont fait le point sur la
situation dans la commune de cocody à
abidjan dans le sud du pays les images
sont signés thomas dyck obadia le récit
d'emilie goog h
avec ces images d'une circulation plutôt
dense on pourrait croire que la vie
continue comme si de rien n'était à
abidjan mais au milieu des voitures des
vendeurs à la sauvette tente d'écouler
du matériel médical
le gouvernement a rendu le port du
masque obligatoire alors c'est un peu
une aubaine pour ces vendeurs de rue qui
vivent au jour le jour pour la main
complément des jeunes demain
à
les âges
même si le confinement n'est pas
obligatoire dans le pays
les ivoiriens sont incités à rester chez
eux mais le secteur informel représente
une part importante de l'économie en
côte d'ivoire alors beaucoup ne peuvent
pas se permettre de s'arrêter de
travailler
d'autant qu'il ya du monde dehors
résultat les mesures barrières sont
rappelés jusque sur des panneaux
d'affichage dans la rue pas suffisant
pour rassurer les habitants
moi je suis inquiet parce que je vois
qu'on ne restez pas les distances demain
tu puis c'est pas tout le monde pourquoi
de les cacher ici
et puis nous n'avons pas tous des gars
au fait on n'a pas tous les moyens aussi
du des pouvoirs sont archi voilà des
gens n'étaient pas en fait le but fois
dès lors on se rend compte que les
mesures annoncées
direction le marché de cocovico toujours
à cocody dans le nord de la capitale
économique
ici plus que dans la rue difficile de
faire respecter les mesures de
distanciation sociale la directrice
gisèle uei est là pour rappeler à
l'ordre commerçants et clients
si besoin
tous les jours je dois passer pour leur
rappeler comme on le dit le savoir acfas
étaient tous les jours donc on obligé de
répéter tout comme dans tout le nord le
pas de calais le poids de la glace à
distance du ca sur les stands
il est parfois compliqué de servir les
clients en respectant les gestes
barrière mais les vendeurs se sentent
plus en sécurité avec leurs masques but
à la duc o
10e que le pouls d'un mois donné
simplement notre santé donc le coach
n'est fait bon c'est le client qui a
fait de toi tu ne sais pas si les il est
malade une sphère car la commerçante au
site une présence en huitièmes malades
d'autres le milieu des portes et on
cache nez
machin c'est pas facile avec les ja des
prud'hommes qui vient du petit peu ce
matin à rennes l'inter 2 qui sent proche
de toi pour mieux communiquer avec toi
bon c'est pas facile de faire un maître
mais en décennies souvent des deux
replis de bourg du dernier de fait à m
autre exemple de la gestion de la
pandémie
devant ce supermarché les clients font
la queue pour se nettoyer les mains
avant d'entrer faire leurs courses à
l'intérieur les rayons ne semble pas
avoir été dévalisées et pour cause
afin d'éviter des ruptures de stock les
clients sont invités à acheter au
maximum quatre articles de la même gamme
l'achat de gel hydroalcoolique et lui
aussi limité